this has been an incredibly difficult
series of
decisions none of which we've taken
lightly
and you've got to recognize and i hope
people do understand this that
when you go into a lockdown it's a very
very
uh painful a traumatic thing for uh for
people for people's mental health for
uh their lives their and their
livelihoods and
of course you've got to set that against
the the horrors of the
of the pandemic and of kobe and
at every stage we've been governed by
a determination to protect life
to save life to ensure that our nhs
is not overwhelmed and we followed uh
to the best we can the the the data and
the and the guidance that we've had and
what we're
doing now is still following the data
still looking very carefully at
where we're going and looking at what's
happening uh with the
uh the new variant did dominic cummings
tell the truth
in his evidence yesterday and
specifically did you say
you would rather see bodies pile high in
the streets than order a third lockdown
i've already made my uh position very
clear on on that point
and i'm you know i'm getting on with the
job of
delivering the the road map that i think
is the sensible way forward
did mr coming to the truth
with uh delivering the the road map that
is the the sensible way forward for this
country so you're not arguing with the
things
the question i i make no comment on that
did you say you would rather see
bodies pile high in the streets than
order a third lockdown i've already made
my
uh position very clear on on that point
and i'm
you know i'm getting on with the job of
delivering
the the road map did matt hancock
promise you that anyone being discharged
from hospital into a care home
would first be tested because mr
cummings said he didn't
mr comey said he promised that yeah no
it didn't happen
we did everything we could to protect
the
nhs and to protect care homes as well
did you test anyone being able to
we did everything we did we did
everything we could to protect
the nhs and to protect care and of
course what happened in care homes
uh was was was tragic and we but we did
everything we could
to protect the nhs to minimize
transmission
with the knowledge that we had one thing
that we we did not
know at the beginning of the pandemic
and don't forget this we did not
know the beginning of the pandemic quite
the way in which the virus could be
transmitted
asymptomatically and that was one of the
reasons that we had
some of the problems that we uh we saw
in in cairns
but what we're doing now is what we're
doing now
what would what we're doing now is what
we're doing now
is trying obviously to protect all
residents in
in all care homes they have a i think
they've all had
uh vaccines up to you know 99 if not 100
and that's the that's the crucial thing
i think that it's
important for us to focus on what really
matters to the people in this country
and i think if i may say so
that uh some of the the commentary i've
heard uh doesn't bear any
relation to reality and what people want
us to get on with
is delivering the the right man